we turned to ethiopia where the
suffering continues after more than a
year after the government launched an
attack in the northern tigray region
rights groups say atrocities including
the mass rape of women and girls have
been committed by parties on both sides
the federal government is still
restricting media and humanitarian
access to degray
meanwhile regions bordering to cry are
on a war footing to grind fighters have
withdrawn back into their home region
but their neighbors are still full of
mistrust dw east africa correspondent
mario muller reports from the amhara
town of lalibela where people are taking
up arms
la libella's rocky churches look
peaceful in the morning light they seem
untouched by the events of the past
months
la bella has twice been captured by
fighters loyal to the tigray people's
liberation front or tplf the town has
now been liberated by government forces
here at bergeron the morning prayers
just ended
this church is one of 11 medieval
churches cut into rock
it has great symbolic value for all
ethiopians this is also why the tplf was
keen to conquer this town
at this time of year one of the holiest
for orthodox christians lalibella is
normally full of international visitors
and diaspora ethiopians
but most of them have stayed away
worried that fighters could swoop in
again from the neighboring tigray region
even though the tplf promised in
december to withdraw
all of their fighters back into tigre
[Music]
many people have fled
those who stayed here we suffered a lot
of stress
they pointed their guns at us the second
time they came they raped women and beat
and killed people
they looted into town and raped and beat
women they looted their hotels we had no
power and water
tigran fighters also attacked the town
of gashena not far from la bella
here we meet a man who doesn't wish to
be identified for fear of tplf
retaliation they killed his uncle he
tells us
and his brother-in-law
when they came they asked for guns and
money
but he's a merchant he's self-employed
when he answered this question they
killed him
they killed many innocent people
they killed 57 civilians here in this
town
he says those buried here weren't
fighters rather mostly traitors like his
brother-in-law claims we could not
independently verify
back in lalibela away from the churches
we meet beyonereta
he used to work as a security guard at
this now destroyed hotel
he tells us some of the tigran fighters
used it as their headquarters
they left messages on the wall before
they left
welcome to state of tigre and no more
ethiopian imt grain the writing says
the tigra fighters were having a
conference here preparing for the war
but then they got hit and the hotel was
destroyed
if we were here together we would have
died
the hotel was probably hit by an armed
drone experts from the dutch ngo parks
have identified these missile fragments
as part of a bomb fitted to a turkish
drone
turkey has been criticized for possibly
selling the drones to ethiopia's
government the drones are also thought
to be responsible for numerous civilian
deaths in ethiopia's civil war
in fact all parties involved in the
conflict have been accused of committing
atrocities according to the united
nations and rights organizations
this kindergarten is now a temporary
camp for volunteer fighters called
whanau group has signed up many new
recruits since the degray rebels first
attacked la la bella
including women
jaima no tadesse is one of them
my uncle and my aunt's husband who
raised me like my own father are dead
my friend who was like a sister to me
was raped she's so young
if i get a chance to find them i will
fight them to my last breath
the whanau fighters are celebrating 50
of them haimanod among them are
traveling to the border between amhara
and tigre the volunteer fighters say
they want to defend the border region in
case the tplf attacks again
you